[Music]
all right chase thanks for being down
here this is lovely we are yadak from
leeds this first song is called
fixer-upper
hello there i got a letter in the post
address to the previous owner i don't
know how you pronounce their name i
don't think that they were from round
here you know well i just moved into the
area yeah that big old thing over the
road
[Music]
and it goes nicely with the existential
fear that i feel when i accidentally
stop and wonder what i'm doing here and
no longer got left before i'm sickly
under eye i can't believe i'm a two-home
owner finally a two-home owner but the
driveway's paid we've got squadstone and
it's austrian parking for your rover
it's a fixer-upper though yeah now not
the rover the rover's golden talking
about that big old thing over the road
yeah that big old thing over the road
we're gonna knock through your kitchen
wall though great to listen in watching
architecture we're gonna absolutely ruin
it all all right we can't stand that
it's a big turtle
[Music]
i'll just post it that returns to sender
unless you know him i think he goes by
the name dr jacobinski on the way
[Music]
probably one of their pointless media
degrees not for me university of life
you see i've got a
[Music]
[Music]
is
the other day the bloody builders are
refusing to finish the job until i pay
him i told him no one pulls a fast one
on graham
i'm dreaming by the way don't know if
i'll mention that i'm not made of money
you're having a laugh two homes and a
rover comes from our craft i'm not
minted i hate it it's not a funny food
new business i didn't walk and build
this splinters to make the dent i did in
under a year i earned it in case you're
wondering and as for the bill that's
happy polish i'm not bothered about that
lie but where you come from says a lot
about a man and i might not be from
around here but i am and also they won't
take cash in that one up maybe they
wouldn't be nobody so bloody but if they
were willingly giving it all to the tax
man they tell you what you could get
where i'm from i'm not from round here
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you cheers
[Applause]
over there
ah
[Music]
your freedom don't come cheap i'm
battering hard with no room to
[Music]
it's hard to see the full extent of the
damage you couldn't see the woods for
the trees help me how am i supposed to
cope in the age of the gentified savage
kids these days think they've been
outdone by never even looked at tonight
and look like i did once they got the
whole thing wrong
[Music]
my day the gear on the street was so
weak could eat your ambition in a matter
of weeks just trying to envision the
peak and that's blake
[Music]
it won't repent
[Music]
look here what you need to understand is
if you want to make some decent money
from it you're better off kicking that
singer you got it out the band
don't be doing originals play the
standards and don't get political i know
what that singer's like he'll end up in
the back of the ambulance with the bikes
that wrapped up his ass twice overall
because he could ignore the flag and be
polisher
show some respect and listen to my
advice because if you don't challenge me
on anything you'll find i'm actually
very nice are you listening
i'm actually very very very nice
the overload of discontents the constant
burden of making sense
[Music]
it won't repent until it made this event
is
how
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
yeah good cool nice one
dark days indeed
the truth was sold that's where the
trail goes cold my shoulders shutter at
the thought of putting my chest out as i
walk home alone under the arches there's
a bloke with a car boot full of stolen
phones knock off cologne and ink
canvases
i see arsonists with business rates
etched on the back of empty match boxes
and police officers getting there
in the bushes wondering what all the
fuss is about and what i think i'm
looking at
but if looks could kill my vacant gaze
wouldn't even pierce the skin i'm not
lazy and this is just something i've no
interest in at least when i meet my
major i'll embrace all my mistakes cause
i descend into the bowels of hell the sh
grin on my face
it's a never-ending cycle of
[Music]
abuse and i can't shake them loose
i had the blues and i can't shake the
moves
it's a never-ending cycle of abuse yeah
well i was skeptic due to how the media
had depicted you though getting to know
your best are we quick until we stop
together turn into corner of the burning
center for those published clutters
stopped us and shook us up and down with
no grounds to an older process started
discussing whether to let us off but
doing nothing our baby couples for
looking like we might be hiding
something then the radio buzzed it
thanks i've got you enough time not to
get shot
it's a never-ending cycle of abuse
i had the blues
[Music]
it's a never-ending cycle of abuse
it's a never-ending cycle of abuser i
had the
it's a never-ending cycle of abuse
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
hey i'm in a quiet tasting if you're
gonna climb the ladder of success on
judgement day take my advice and
reinvent the reel
completely
believe me
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers total refreshment center thanks
this will be our last two nice one
thanks to james for having us thanks to
selector radio and the british council
the song is called land of the blind it
will be our next single in several weeks
time
and our album is out on the 7th of
january if you're so inclined to uh
buy it
[Music]
to a liquid narrative
obviously i tried writing you out of the
will well
i just didn't have the guts to lie
through my teeth though only because i'm
susceptible to the truth on the bleakest
of moons and
though there is a beauty and a whole
truth the naughty roots of a shameful
past we'll never let it be
these new suits and escape routes
loot the debris and make no mistake we
are living out our last days in the land
of the blind where the one-eyed man was
king till he went to lost his mind
[Music]
a quick whip around for the log
suffering house band whilst peace
treaties are breached so we can all
knock about heart naked on the beaches
off some far off foreign land and
we all get a commemorative 50 pence
piece each for the peace treaties breach
and the palms grease which are never on
the ends of the elbows digging the
graves of the recently deceived please
have a seat i'm going to show you all a
magic trick
it's sort of a surprise so if you could
just let me that 50 pence piece in your
hand and close your eyes
i'm going to make me and this 50 pence
piece disappear
[Music]
bow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers thank you enjoy your evening
thanks london
[Applause]